hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the aimchess u.s rapid
knockouts it's vladislav artemia versus
saliresa feruzia and this is already
quite the game it's a game from round
one and although it's uh somewhat long
some 60 moves everything happens really
quickly and it's like it's a really
short game you'll see what i mean uh so
let's dive straight into it uh artemis
with the white pieces opens with c4 he
goes for the english opening we have e6
biology g3 and now uh we have d5
striking in the center uh we have bishop
to g2 and the knight to f6 uh we have
knight to f3 and now uh bishop to e7 so
basically we transpose into neocatalin
uh we have castle's castles and now b3
uh we have c5 uh grabbing more space in
the center and now our trade and uh on
d5 we have calculus characters and
bishop to b2 our team of finquetos is
dark square bishop
we have knight to c6 and now d4 so this
has all been played before nothing new
here knights to e4 by alireza and now d
captures on c5 we have bishop captures
and now knight to c3 challenging this
bishop here but also attacking this d5
pawn twice so knight captures on c3
bishop captures and now d4 alireza
advances his pawn to d4 which kind of
stifles white's development as you will
have some problems playing e3
but this is nothing new we have bishop
back to b2 and the bishop to f5 so black
develops uh his pieces very naturally
and without much
much trouble uh so here we have rook to
c1 attacking the bishop here and alireza
defends it with queen to d6 and now
artemis plays a really awesome move it's
not a new one but still a really awesome
one and that is b4 uh this move has
nothing to do with the evan's gambit but
i still made it a thumbnail because it's
really awesome so basically the idea is
similar you to uh you want black to
capture with the bishop or the knight
and then black will lose some control of
the over the d4 pawn and then you can
grab this very strong d4 pawn and it
doesn't help you to ignore this if you
move the bishop just b5 chases away the
knight and then the pawn is free uh so
here uh after this b for move we have uh
knight captures and b4 b bishop captures
on b4 was played in the in the game that
i'm uh referring to but knight captures
on b4 is a new move so already now as of
move 15 we have a completely new game uh
let's see how white deals with this uh
we have knight characters on d4 uh
bishop capture sunday for we have queen
capture sunday for uh queen capture
sunday for and bishop captures on d4 so
everything gets traded off the board and
now you as you can see white still has
the bishop pair and the bishop pair is
fully operational uh it will be
uh well it's not going to be easy
defending tho those queenside pawns and
while you could capture the spawn on a2
then we're gonna play rook to a1 attack
the knight you can't really go back
because bishop c5 now attacks the the
rook and the knight so you would have to
defend it with the bishop and now we
simply catch run b7 and it's uh well
just a very tough position for black to
play rook will move we're going to bring
the other rook to b1 now this pawn is
hanging and it's uh well it's just a
very very interesting position
uh so uh here instead after bishop
captures on d4 alireza says all right
i'm gonna play knight to c6 i'm going to
sacrifice a pawn but you're going to
have to give up one of your bishops and
i'm going to try and fight you uh being
down upon and artemiv accepts this he
plays bishop captures on c6 b captures
and bishop captures so now we have this
position uh where the material is uh
not equal of course our teammate is up a
pawn but the bishops are of opposite
colors so if alireza manages to
trade off the rooks then he will have
excellent drawing chances we have rook f
the e8 putting pressure on the pawn here
and now just e3 defending it we have
rook e to c8 now
trying to trade off
a pair of rooks and now rook back to c1
we have bishop to d3 attacking this rook
and now rook f2 e1 and now a5 alireza
starts uh advancing his a pawn and g4
now at some point of course you want to
bring your king into the board play h4
f4 but for the moment just keep an eye
on black's kingside pawns we have bishop
to c4 now
attacking the a2 pawn and a3 we have
bishop back to e6 attacking this pawn
and now h3 defending it and now a4 so
the pawn will be very nicely placed here
you can always defend it with bishop to
b3 uh and black will have to keep an eye
on the a3 sorry white will have to keep
an eye on the a3 pawn with his bishop so
king h2 artemiev starts bringing the
king into the game and now it is oh it
is a trades a pair of rooks we have rook
captures rook captures and rook to c8 uh
of course he would very much enjoy
trading rooks but artemyev knows that
this would only help black draw the game
so rook to d1
we have bishop to b3 chasing that rook
away and rook to d3 now we have f6
uh blocking this bishop somewhat and now
we have king to g3 now further uh
improving the position of the king king
f7 alireza does the same
bishop back to b6 and now king the e6 we
have bishop to a5 now the bishop can
also come to the b4
and h5 now trying to
uh will ruin black white's
pawn structure on the king side we have
bishop to b4 now with some ideas of
maybe annoying black with some rook to
d6 check ideas but it's not a problem
just h captures on g4 h captures and now
rook to c6 not allowing this and here
alireza is asking artemis how are you
gonna get through so first we have rook
to d8
uh maybe maybe going after that
g7 pawn also you could deliver some
checks from behind so rook the c7 and
now f4 and now as you can see uh not a
lot of squares for this black king the
pawns are really doing a fine job
covering all of this the rook is cutting
off the king from the d file bishop
covers the e8 square so basically f7 is
the only square available to the king at
the moment with g6 of course you do not
want to allow f5 if f5 is played then
it's going to be trouble for the black
king so g6 preventing this and now well
you could uh strike with e4 right away
now artemis first moves the black king
back with king to f7 and now e4
uh we have looked at e7 attacking uh the
e4 pawn and now king to f3 defending it
we have rook to c7 alireza is waiting to
see what artemis does king to e3 now we
have bishop back to e6 going after the
g4 pawn but now artemis advances it to
f5 we have g captures and f5 g captures
on f5 and now bishop back to b3 uh and
again alireza is asking artemis how are
you going to win this and here
while you could go for a move like uh
like king to d4 right away uh first we
have rook to b6 uh artemis waiting to
see what alireza will do as alireza is
down on time i think he had around the
minute on the clock whereas artemis had
some three minutes on the clock here
we have bishop to c2 and now king to d4
we have rooked the d7 check forcing the
king back and now king to e3 uh you
could you can go to e5 of course the
pawn is preventing the king so uh king
the c5 is possible but then of course
you blunder the pawn so we have to go
back king e3 now comes rook to c7 and
again how is artemyev going to break
through he plays rook to e6 now now if
black isn't careful and moves the rook
away from the c file maybe we can even
attack this f6 pawn so bishop to b3 of
course the rook will remain on the c
file and now rook to a6 we have bishop
to c2 and bishop the d6 now uh trying to
chase the rook away we've rooked the c3
with check king to f4 and now bishop to
d1
here trying to
deliver a very tricky rook to f3 check
so here we rook the a7 check king the g8
and now uh there is only one thing you
can do here uh that's uh
that could lead to a victory for white
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the only way out of this uh and for
those who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course uh e5 uh and while you
could deliver a check first and then
throw throw in a few checks if you want
to you know win some time on the clock
you're gonna have to play e5 eventually
so e5 congratulations to everyone who
found it you are an amazing player
and now what do you do here uh well you
could capture it but then the problem is
after captures captures all of these
squares are covered the real covers f7
the bishop covers f8 and we're just
going to start advancing our pawn so
instead after e5 uh we have bush rook to
see for chuck king back to e3 and now
again it's the same thing if you capture
f6 now now it's even worse and the the
pawn is unstoppable so here we have rook
the c6 attacking the bishop here so now
if you advance the pawn we're going to
pick up the bishop uh but now rook to a8
with check and if you go to f7 then it's
a problem then rook to f8 to check we're
going to move the king and now he
captures on f6 comes with check king h7
and bishop to e5 in that game we're
going to play f7 and hopefully check
made the black king or you know
at the worst that we're going to promote
our pawn to a queen so after rook day a8
check we have king to h7 violin but now
comes e captures an f6 boldly
sacrificing the bishop but of course if
the bishop is captured f7 just wins
there's no stopping the pawn so here
alireza played bishop to b3 preventing
the pawn from reaching f7 but now rook
to a7 check and also guarding the f7
square king to g8 and now rook to g7
with check king to h8 and now of course
bishop to e5 and there really isn't
anything else for alireza to do here uh
the idea is f7 and then the bishop will
be simply unstoppable so rook to c5 uh
black's last attempt going after the
bishop on e5 but now already oh sorry
artemiev ends the game in great style by
playing just bishop to d4 and there is
nothing more to be done here for black
so it was in this position on move 59
that alireza firuja resigned the game
and the first game goes to vladislav
artemyev uh now the the reason uh for
the resignation is you have to move the
rook uh as it's attacked and it doesn't
matter where you move it you could even
capture a pawn but f7 is just uh
unstoppable uh you open up at this
diagonal and the the black king cannot
move there's nothing you can do if you
capture the pawn of course we just
captured the rook with check so you
can't capture back with the bishop and
if you don't do anything uh well then
uh you know we can deliver a check then
bring a queen into the game doesn't
really matter everything wins here we
can just move our rook deliver a check
and then pick up this rook so
absolutely everything wins here so after
bishop to d4 uh farouja resigned and a
great start for artemiv in their uh
first semi-final match
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it like i said uh it's uh kind of a long
game 59 moves but actually a really
short one uh so uh once again i really
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank uh hayden queenie aditya paris
christopher alexander sopa tom derelo
and cake defy dot com for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
semi-finals uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day